our doctor Tara Narula is a cardiologist
at northwell health in New York and she
joins us once again Tara I know you have
a lot to discuss but before you do I
just wanted to talk about your piece
yesterday because I honestly can't stop
thinking about it we were all we all
felt some kind of way when you hear a
doctor say I'm scared I'm worried I'm
afraid you just don't hear doctors speak
this way and that's really why we wanted
to tell this story you know we never
open up as doctors about our own
vulnerabilities we run into the room we
take care of people when they're dying
when they're bleeding when they're in
pain and we comfort them but we're human
too and so it was very important to show
that side and doctors are scared and
they're really scared because they feel
like they're going to not only be
infected themself but more importantly
the risk of infecting their family and
they feel like they're having to make a
choice that no one should have to make
which is a choice between a profession
that you took an oath for to heal and
protect and serve others and your family
and what do you do when you're in that
position so you know the feedback we got
from the piece yesterday was just all
these you know healthcare professionals
saying I was crying yes you know we're
not even near the peak here of what
we're expecting to be up against when
you look at the numbers of other
countries what what do what do we
potentially face here well it depends it
depends how good we socially distance
and how good we follow all the public
health measures we're talking about so
certainly we have seen a plateau a
decrease in the numbers from China and
South Korea that's encouraging it tells
us that if you follow these measures now
granted those were aggressive and they
had more testing you can slow it and
that's why it's really important for
Americans to understand that this term
of flattening the curve and social
distancing it's powerful those aren't
just empty words they mean some they
mean something to me protecting our
vulnerable they mean decreasing the
impact on the healthcare system one of
the things that's very important for
people to understand is what is going on
in Italy those doctors talk about a
difficult decision they're having to
make decisions like in wartime about
triage meaning I can't save you I won't
save you because you're older and you're
sicker and you're not going to survive
imagine being put in that position and
that's what we could face here you have
a benefit of care calculation if it's an
older /
and taking the bed or a younger person
we really hope that doesn't come here
we've got the Navy sending to ships the
army setting up field hospitals but I'm
interested in Intelli
medicine remote medicine as a solution
for doctors it would reduce their
physical risk is that really a stand-in
it is I mean it's it's kind of the
perfect thing for a pandemic we're doing
that in my hospital system were you know
condensing the number of visits and
we're using telemedicine so it can never
replace that in-person visit right but
it can go a long way and so I think
right now in the situation we're in it's
really a great tool for us and I think
it's going to allow the field to really
grow and expand we heard about the self
swab test yesterday the president
mentioned that what do you think about
that do we know enough to self swab
ourselves just self test so just
yesterday there's a company that
announced it will be releasing and
producing a self swab test do months I
think it's a good idea in the sense that
we can use it more widely it's again
safer in the sense that you're not
having somebody come into the office and
expose themselves doctors and health
care professionals are not exposed
there's some experience the self swab
but we're so swapping our nose right how
do we know to do that nose well it's
relative it's not going to be like the
kind you see that's very aggressive yeah
well that's what we really need to
figure out right and and that will give
us more of a sense of the widespread
this is and one other thing that's in
the works is also these antibody or
blood tests those are really going to
look at who has had the infection at
some point and that will give us the
best picture of how the virus is
spreading and what the true mortality
rate is all right Tara Narula thank you
so much